[Music]
[Applause]
good evening and welcome to the table my
name is Juanita Johnson I'm one of the
elders here on the table in Dallas Texas
we are so excited that you have chosen
to join us this evening for our worship
service it is our hope and prayer that
some things evening is nourishment to
you is helpful in your week
so yes thank you for joining us I do
hope that you find something in the
service assuming that is good I would
like to share a couple of announcements
with you the first is about our meetups
even though we are all still social
distancing and observing
just the challenges of this pandemic we
have continued to hold our meetups
virtually I want to tell you about two
meetups tonight the first is Daryl's
meetup this is for all men and those who
identify as male they meet on the first
and third Tuesday of the month and it is
a place for encouragement and support
and prayer and worship together for men
so guys can do your and things together
and I think Karen's gonna put Daryl's
email information in the show notes so
if you will check that out if you're
interested if you're looking for a
community or support Darrell's a really
good guy and so I hope that you'll
connect with him the other meetup that
we have is Maggie's
teen girls group is actually taking a
break for part of July and she is
hosting a racial awareness teen racial
awareness group and this is a four week
small group for all teens and they are
gonna walk through some racial awareness
they're gonna read a book and do some
talking and processing together it's
gonna last weeks starting on July 15th
them and it will end right before school
year starts given all that's going on in
the country if you have a teenager
that's walking into the the next school
year this will be a great opportunity
for them to process some of their
thoughts and feelings and to learn
together
I know Maggie's really excited and some
of her girls that are participating so
if you have a team that would be
interested that Maggie's email will also
be in the notes section so please reach
out and connect I know that that's gonna
be a really good group a really powerful
opportunity and it's a short you know
it's a short meet up so you know that it
has a beginning and it has an end your
teens are committing to a long process I
hope you'll check that out again that
starts on July 15th
all right so we're gonna transition into
our time of worship and since I pre
record these it's really difficult for
me to have a prayer that feels authentic
so I thought I'd share with you this
evening a passage that I come back to
often
just because in
all that's happening in the world it's
hard to find true north it's
it's really easy to spiral or get lost
and all of the chaos in this particular
passage for me is really it's a it helps
me stay focused on Who am I called to be
what am I called to do even in the midst
of chaos and this is from Isaiah 58
starting in verse 6
it reads is not this the kind of fasting
I have chosen to lose the chains of
injustice and untie the cords of the
yoke to set the oppressed free and to
break every yoke is it not to share your
food with a hungry and to provide the
poor wanderer with shelter when you see
the naked to clothe them and not to turn
away from your own flesh and blood then
your light will break forth like the
dawn and your healing will quickly
appear then your righteousness will go
before you and the glory of the Lord
we'll be your rear guard then you will
call and the Lord will answer you will
cry for help and he will say here am i
if you do away with the yoke of
oppression with a pointing finger and
malicious talk and if you spend
yourselves in behalf of the hungry and
satisfy the needs of the oppressed then
your light will rise in the darkness and
your night will become like the noonday
the Lord will guide you always he will
satisfy your needs in the school Sun
scorched land and will strengthen your
frame you will be like a well watered
garden like a spring whose waters never
fail your people will rebuild the
ancient ruins and will raise up the
age-old foundations you will be called
repair of broken walls restorer of
streets with dwellings
I'm going to stop there I think it's
really easy to look at the chaos of the
world and and get overwhelmed and think
I don't know where to start and this
passage it I love the end to be a repair
of a different person says repair of the
breach but in the beginning it starts
really simple of things that we can all
do it's if you see someone hungry to
feed them if you see them struggling you
know to find clothes or shelter to
provide for them to stop malicious
finger-pointing and tongue wagging
and I think these are really simple
tasks and that but they have a big
impact so if you're struggling to know
where to start it's starting your own
house starting your own neighborhood if
you know there needs to reach out and be
someone to provide what you have and
that will go a long way you will be part
of repairing the breach and restoring
age-old foundations so I hope you are
blessed I hope you enjoy the rest of the
service
[Music]
the agency forgets
tomorrow and today
go away go
pages the gifts I
can
maybe
[Music]
hey guys
again even though we can't see your
faces I am imagining you guys and
hoping that your well tonight I was
thinking about worship and the way that
sometimes I can approach worship I'm not
sure if it's this way for you guys but
when we say that word like let's worship
together I feel like we immediately get
this picture or I do this picture in my
mind like I've the sanctuary and our
eyes are closed and maybe our hands are
lifted and there's ambience and there's
lighting and sound systems in a band and
not exactly what we've been experiencing
the last while in this pandemic state um
but I do feel like sometimes all of that
extra stuff can kind of set us up for
failure in some ways it's beautiful and
it's an amazing experience and
definitely a way that we can experience
God in a different atmosphere than what
we're used to a different setting but
sometimes it can cause me to feel like I
need to create a moment otherworldly and
and I've kind of defined what that would
mean what that would look like you know
to experience something that I don't
experience in my everyday life with God
and I'm not sure why we go there I'm
sure there's a lot of reasons if I try
to unpack it but I was reading this
passage and first John and it encouraged
me because like we sing these words
some of the words that we're gonna be
singing tonight that can definitely
contribute to this feeling of like
creating an amazing moment Holy Spirit
come flood this place fill the
atmosphere I want to be overcome by your
presence let the glory of God be all
that we long and you know set a fire in
my soul
and I feel like it can kind of take us
to this place where we're like I want to
feel something different but I know what
my normal everyday life is like and it
usually doesn't feel like something
extra special
but I experience God and I know like the
moments when I'm playing with my kids
and they make me laugh really hard like
there's God pieces in that where I take
a walk and I look around me and I watch
Birds take care of their young or I mean
just all these little moments lately but
I've just been feeling the presence of
God in everyday normal life and I know
that he's there and and I feel like
there's something really beautiful about
the ordinary and finding God in it and
so I just wanted to read this verse real
quick as we go into worship it's in
first John 4 verse 12 no one has ever
seen God but if we love one another God
lives in US and his love is made
complete in US and I just can't imagine
something more powerful than that God
living in US and his love being complete
in us and so I hope that whatever you're
doing tonight if your kids are running
around or maybe you have friends that
are with you or
maybe you've been missing your friends
and your family during this quarantine
season and
maybe you'll go outside and and
experience God in the everyday ordinary
moments as he is with us and it doesn't
mean that we have to be in a sanctuary
or experience the whole band although
that would be nice I'm missing my
bandmates but I hope that tonight we're
experiencing God right where we're at
and and almost experiencing each other
in the midst of that even in our
separate homes in our separate places so
yeah I just encourage you to find him in
these lyrics maybe in a new way
in a different way that doesn't feel
otherworldly sometimes it's finding him
in this world right where we're at
[Music]
Holy
Spirit you are welcome here
this place and fill the atmosphere
your glory
God is what our hearts long for to be
overcome
by your presence
spirit
[Music]
place and fill the atmosphere
your
glory
I hurt my boy to be Oh
by your presence
no please have a baby no place I'd
rather be no place I'd rather be
then here in your love here in your love
no place I'd rather be no place I'd
rather be
no place I'd rather be here in your love
here in your
I
[Music]
can't
I
[Applause]
no place I'd rather be no place I'd
rather be no place I'd rather be
[Music]
[Applause]
no place I'd rather be no place I'd
rather be and here in your love here in
your
I can't
[Music]
[Applause]
wonderfully made your Renard is into par
there and the case and the clay in the
unearthing has been wasted
[Music]
you're not finished with me
you know that list with me
[Music]
so set a fire down in my soul I can't
contain I can't control I want more of
you
I want
[Music]
to set a fire down in my soul that I
can't contain I can't control I want
more
[Music]
I want
Jesus thank you for meeting us right now
right
no matter how well we're doing you are
here anywhere with us
you're continuing to do your work in our
hearts
continuing to mold us and shape us into
a person that looks more like Jesus and
God that's what we ask
we want more of you in our lives we want
to be more like the hands and the feet
of Jesus that take care of the sick and
the hungry and the lonely that have ears
to hear the voices of those who others
would ignore
God make us present to you and your
spirit and what you're doing in our
lives
we love who you are
and we're so grateful that you love us
for who we are
it's in your name that we ask all these
things and thank you for being with us
good
amen
[Music]
hello everyone welcome to the table
grace in peace it's yeah really really
good to be with you all and um let's see
I wanted to name before we jump in
tonight just kind of let you know that I
will be taking a few weeks off from the
table beginning tomorrow
so come as a church community we really
value um rest rhythms and
so July is kind of our time to dial it
back a bit and obviously this year is a
little bit unique well we're the little
this year's really unique and so I
thought about just not taking this time
but um you know all things considered
it's been a really intense year and so
it just it seemed wise to take some
space so we're gonna have a number of
guest speakers coming up from our
community you're gonna be preaching on
over that two weeks it's gonna be really
fresh and unique and powerful
so I'm just I'm looking forward to you
all being able to hear from them and
also if you're part of a meet-up go
ahead and check with your leader just to
see kind of their plan because some of
them are gonna be taking some time off
so yeah check in alright so we are in
this is part 3 in our series on the
Gospel of Luke I've gotten some good
feedback on this this series it seems
like it's connecting with you all which
is great
so we've kind of neh the last few weeks
that but basically for just a little
context on Luke that it's it's kind of
the ancient equivalent of a documentary
film about the life of Jesus so Luke
he's writing 30 to 50 years after the
resurrection in Ascension of Jesus he
has interviewed people who were
eyewitnesses of Christ Luke has
researched the accounts the earlier
written accounts that we now have it in
the Bible as the Gospel of Matthew the
Gospel of Mark so he's he's kind of
interviewed eyewitnesses
um he has taken the accounts of Matthew
and Mark and he's kind of editing and
putting together this kind of written
documentary which has been preserved for
us so that's a little background it's
specifically tonight the title of my
message is the having mode and our text
is gonna be Luke chapter six verses 27
through 36 so Jesus is teaching the
people and he is sane verse 27 but to
you who are listening I say love your
enemies
do good to those who hate you bless
those who curse you pray for those who
mistreat you if someone slaps you on one
cheek turn to them the other also if
someone takes your coat do not withhold
your shirt from them verse 30 give to
everyone who asks of you and if anyone
takes what belongs to you do not demand
it back verse 31 do to others as you
would have them do to you if you love
those who love you what credit is that
to you even sinners love those who love
them and if you do good to those who are
good to you what credit is that to you
even sinners do that and if you lend to
them from whom you expect repayment what
credit is that to you even sinners lend
to sinners expecting to be repaid in
full
but love your enemies do good to them
lend to them without expecting to get
anything back then your reward will be
great and you will be children of the
Most High because he is kind to the
ungrateful and wicked
be merciful just as your father is
merciful
so this this text really is one of if
not the
high points of the teachings of Jesus
and in he's describing a mode of life a
way of being in the world that to to
American ears even in a so-called
Christian nation that it really probably
strikes us as
borderline
I don't know what would you call it
wild-eyed fanaticism
like this really is just too much and
where it becomes too much for us I think
it's not so much in the broad stroke
statements you love your enemies because
that's sufficiently vague and can be
interpreted in ways that kind of allow
us to carry on with our lives as usual
just now with a certain veneer of
Christian niceness towards everyone kind
of you know painted across the top like
you know enough that we can say things
like oh sure sure yes I I love everyone
yes yes
so it's not so much that it's it's all
the examples of how
love for an enemy would look that I
mean what can we say it's uh
it's just not how the world works I mean
we'll just hit on a few of these verse
28 bless those who curse you pray
for those who mistreat you if someone
slaps you on one cheek you turned it in
the other also if someone takes your
coat well do not withhold your shirt
lend to your enemies I mean that's
enough right like hey lend to your
enemies oh no he keeps going without
expecting to be repaid in full now
what's so interesting about these
examples is that they cover so much of
human life right the first to cover
speech bless those who curse you pray
for those who mistreat you the next one
covers bodily harm if someone slaps you
on one cheek offer up the other one the
final to cover possessions if someone
steals from you will make sure they
don't leave without a little something
extra and you know consider offering
them alone as they walk out the door
what is going here I think Jesus is he's
he's pulling on a thread that just might
unravel our entire way of life
you've had that experience of course
every human essence of pulling on a
thread you know to say like a shirt or a
pair of shorts whatever and you think
it's just gonna be a quick little yank
and then you can move on with your day
and so you give it you know that's right
a pole and it goes with you right it's
the classic moment like whoa and you
look down and you're you know part of
your shirts gone you go frustrated you
yank again and again and you start
getting them more of a rage like you
pull harder and before you know it's
like a imagine you sort of a cartoon
character and I like Tom & Jerry or
something and or the shirt you know it's
just disappearing because they're just
and that's sort of what Jesus is doing
here um he is he's yanking on the thread
of human human kind of relationships
human culture because I mean these
examples that he's giving of how we
relate to
everyone including our worst enemies it
goes right to the heart of how we live
um right to the heart of what I'm gonna
call our our kind of our mode of being
our way of being in the world and in our
way of being
when someone talks down to us when
someone speaks poorly of us
we're not going to let that happen we're
going to verbally tear them to shreds or
if we're nice Christian people
perhaps we won't say anything but to
respond to words of spite and anger and
ugliness with blessing and kindness and
compassion like are you a crazy person
I'm not gonna do that and then
furthermore if someone physically
mistreats me I'm gonna punch them right
in the nose and or prosecute them to the
fullest extent of the law and someone
takes my stuff my things that I have
spent my life my blood sweat tears
you--you'll 18 I'm I'm freakin coming
after them and if you think I'm just
gonna lay down like a doormat if you
think I'm just gonna I'm just gonna like
just lay there oh sure go ahead
take all my cell like you've got another
freaking thing coming I deserve better
than this
I think that's a pretty good rant so now
here's what's interesting though it's a
funny thing isn't it that Jesus was so
clear the whole time I mean wouldn't you
what did I think he meant when he said
if anyone wants to come after me they
must deny themselves take up their cross
and follow me
what what exactly did I think I was
signing up for well I'm not quite sure
but
it certainly was not this
now I want to contend that it's often
right at this moment I know where your
brains are going I know you I know
because my brain goes there that we get
stuck in messages like this because our
our brain starts gonna play in this out
and
we sort of extrapolate out and we say
okay wait a second if if I started
living like this like I actually did
this just imagine what could happen and
then we start you know jumping to kind
of to the end you know to these kind of
extreme examples
examples by the way that I actually do
think hold marriage like I'm not trying
to brush these off to the side or
something um I think the two classic
examples that at least in every
conversation with anyone I've had on
these topics about like specifically
over whether or not to use force
I think here's the two examples that
come to mind um what if someone broke
into your house and was trying to hurt
your kid would you say blessings upon
you my friend
peace of the Lord be with you alright
that's the first thing that's everyone
always says like what about that and
then be um what about Hitler that's Oh
Hitler always has to make his way
and when we use those extreme examples
um I think kind of what we start to do
is in a sense like I get why we're going
there and like I said and I try to brush
those away I would be fascinated by a
conversation you know on those topics um
but I think in ways we kind of used the
extreme to then justify the status quo
of our life today like how we're living
and reacting and responding today so
what I'd like to suggest is that we
bracket out those extreme examples
tonight I'll just kind of put those to
the side let's not use them as a way of
letting ourselves off the hook tonight
because when we do that I think
we can actually start to hear that Jesus
is inviting us into a whole new mode of
being in the world that that is actually
the best way to live
so there's a brilliant book a little
book by the psychologist Erich Fromm
that I read last summer it's called to
have or to be and when I read it it was
one of those like aha moments I was like
and what from unpacks is he says there
are there are two modes two ways of
being that humans kind of get into in
and lives in inhabit and it's not that
one is good and the other evil you know
one is good or bad they both have their
place and they are here's the two modes
they are the having mode and
the being mode ah now because we are in
a body we do in fact need or we need the
having mode if you do not have water for
example you will die if you do not have
some food or some shelter you'll make it
and so rightly your body is in doubt of
this capacity to to have to obtain to
possess having is about
control over so for example when I grab
the glass of water and and I you know
fill it up and then I raise it to my
lips I am controlling the glass and I
use it to obtain what I need I'm in the
having mode now to be in the having mode
is to manipulate to control to possess
things and again nothing wrong with the
having mode so where do we go wrong well
we begin to think that all of life is
about what is about the having mode it's
about control it's about possession it's
having having money possessing things
getting power and you can see we're in
that kind of moment where we're
beginning to go sideways because of
course it's one thing to possess to
control to manipulate a thing a a tool
like a glass of water it's quite another
to relate to who in this way people
and this is why we don't understand what
Jesus is getting at because we are so
used to relating to people in what the
theologian Martin Buber he called it in
I it
relationship I - it where I am the I and
you are the object
it and I use you I abuse you I I get
back at you I hurt you i punish you and
I don't relate to you as holy holy holy
because I'm in the having mode can you
see like how this plays out in the world
you're probably right now you can think
in your own life of like examples
where you've been in this mode and where
others have treated you right this way
and this is why I think we can't make
heads or tails of Jesus teaching here
because we live in a world I'm thinking
specifically of Western culture where
everything and everyone has been
commoditized what do I mean commoditize
I mean they are a a commodity they are a
rom
Tyrael to be kind of bought and sold and
switched out and used and then replaced
for me to get ahead
all right so what's the opposite of the
having mode
the being mode and in the B mode this is
this is what like Christian spirituality
is actually interested in I really think
Jesus as he related to people and and
spoke about the kingdom of God and in
relationship connection the father I
mean I think really he's talking
constantly about the being mode Jesus
wasn't really so much interested in like
you know how much money someone's making
or how great of a success they are you
know by quote-unquote worldly standards
the having mode standards Jesus is
interested in what in who you and I are
becoming and and being or becoming is is
about inner growth it's not about doing
something so much as it is it's about
becoming something you see it being is
about deepening our love
deepening our sense of peace
deepening our sense of meaning and
purpose
deepening our
maturity being is also about
relationality
when not I and it but I and you or use
the King James I and thou
where we become
together I
I came across a great example of this of
kind of this teaching from Professor
John ver of baekje that I've linked to
him in my e-letter I think I've
mentioned him in previous messages so he
gives a wonderful kind of example in his
series of lectures on on the meaning
crisis which can find on YouTube but
this is kind of his example and his it's
he discussed though of the language we
have around sex so so we have
sex we make love can you hear the
difference in that language right - to
have sex is to use a person it is to
relate to them in an I it fashion
whereas to make love is what is to enter
into the depths of relationality that
there's a sense of togetherness right
this is what relationship is it is where
we are both in the being mode where we
are becoming together and that's not of
course just restricted to romantic
relationships like this is this is our
life right we are in becoming together
and so when I read Jesus words here what
I see him saying is that there will be
people who are not awake they have not
been
born-again to use the language of the
gospel John why what is that a metaphor
they they are lost in the darkness of
relating to
everything and everyone in the having
mode and that's why they relate to you
as an enemy that's why they curse you
that's why they're trying to win and
stomp you out why they want to ruin you
why they mistreat and slap and curse and
steal and demand your coat and demand
your money it's why they abuse and
exploit you and in that moment you and I
face a tremendous temptation
will we respond in kind will we do the
same back to them that's the question
will you relate to them in the having
mode -
will you relate to them
as an object to pour out your spite in
frustration in rage upon or will you
relate to them as holy holy holy as a
precious child of God and in what if
what if their only chance of being saved
what if the only chance of that really
our world has of being saved is if you
and I do precisely that
you see here's the question
what if there were no such thing as
enemies
but only wayward members of the family
what if there were no such thing as
enemies but only wayward members of the
family how would you relate to them
differently you see cuz here's what I'm
getting at with family we tend to relate
to them in the being mode
and of course not saying literally every
family does its right of course there's
a super mess of families but just
generally speaking right this this is
why um we would probably have far fewer
objections to what Jesus is saying here
when it's about our mother our brother
our daughter
because there's something almost
instinctual in us that that we we relate
to them in the beam mode we relate to
them as holy holy holy even when they
steal from us even when they hurt us we
still relate to them in the beam mode
and
by the way I don't think that means that
there is no such thing as boundaries
right this is why I'm still I'm not
trying to brush aside the extreme
examples the the big movements of oh my
gosh but I think what it what it does
mean is that that even those extreme
examples we have to wrestle with what
does it mean to treat even them not as
in it an object
but to treat them as holy holy holy
even my worst enemy holy holy holy I and
thou and
that's I think that's the the depths of
the wrestling that we have to
engage as followers of Christ
so Fuad banan he was an arab christian
pastor in beirut after the last
arab-israeli war and during that time
his congregation faced a really really
grave dilemma so the year it was 1983
and israeli army's they drove in the
lebanon and so everyone including
members of the church they began to buy
up all the canned food that they could
to survive a rumored Israeli siege so
and West Beirut was basically totally
cut off from the outside world and so
the leaders of the church they met to
decide um how do we distribute the food
that that we've purchased and two
proposals were debated
the first was to distribute food to the
church members and then to other
Christians and then last if any was left
to their Muslim neighbors
the other proposal was different first
food would be given to Muslim neighbors
then to other Christians in then finally
if any food was left to the church
members so they had this meeting and the
meeting literally lasted six hours spent
on set
and they were at a bit of a stalemate
but it ended when an older a quiet much
respected elder a woman stood up and
said if we do not demonstrate
the love of Christ in this place
who will
and
in that moment
the decision it was me and
all week I've I've really been unable to
get that
those LDAP that elders words out of my
head that that if you and I do not
demonstrate the love of Christ in this
place in our world who will you see I
think we need to kind of flip the script
where every slight every bitter word
from an enemy every stolen good every
wrong suffered is it's now an
opportunity where we get to demonstrate
to the world what it is to live without
fear in resentment to have no enemies
but instead to exist in the beam mode
will you pray with me Lord Jesus
truthfully Lord I just I feel like a
beginner in all of this
and I suspect I'm not alone and so Lord
which you show us the path would you
teach us to
exist in the beam mode to relate to
others in the beam mode
to to at least as far as it depends on
us I'm have no enemies
what help us to love
help us to be a community that loves
God mature us deepen us
show us the way for in the powerful and
life-changing name of Jesus I pray
amen you all have a great week
[Music]
for a spa cooler
you were singing over me
you have been so so good
to me
before I took a breath blue reads your
life in me
you have been some soul
the overwhelming
[Music]
never-ending list love of God
oh it chased me down fights till I'm
found
[Music]
and I couldn't turn it and I don't
deserve it
still you
[Music]
overwhelming
never-ending
when I was
still your love
for me
you've been so so good
No
you've been so
[Music]
don't deserve
me
please
[Music]
to me
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you so much for choosing to be
with us here at the table virtually and
we hope that something in the message
was helpful for you to this evening and
we're gonna keep the comment section
open for a little while longer just so
we can say our goodbyes don't be a
stranger throughout the week if you have
need please reach out you can check out
our website and send it shoot us an
email
we want to we're still the church you
know the pandemic is happening but we
are still a church and we want to
support one another during these greatly
times to close out I thought I would
just read the last bit of that passage
from Isaiah it is a
call to action for myself it is it is my
life I don't know if life's verse those
are weird but it is just something that
I find very encouraging so I want to
read it to you all again and I hope that
you're encouraged I hope that you have a
wonderful week so I'll just read this
and we'll close out
this is starting in verse 11 the Lord
will guide you always he will satisfy
your needs in a sun-scorched land and
will strengthen your frame you will be
like a well watered garden like a spring
whose waters never fail your people will
rebuild the ancient ruins and will raise
up the age-old foundations you will be
called repair of broken walls restorer
of streets with dwellings amen have a
great week
you